[Applause]
with Prince Harry and Megan Markel's I
choose fast approaching here's all the
latest in royal wedding news the
lovebirds were all smiles on Thursday
arriving at Windsor Castle to finalize
wedding preparations and reportedly meet
the Queen for tea
Megan opted for a semi casual look for
the occasion it seems she's even
sporting a new hairstyle ahead of her
big day
meanwhile Prince William and Kate
Middleton were photographed leaving
Kensington Palace and making their way
to Windsor for afternoon rehearsals as
for someone who isn't gearing up for the
royal wedding Megan's father Thomas
Markel who was set to walk his daughter
down the aisle prior to suffering a
heart attack that required him to
undergo surgery a royal source tells ET
that despite the palace offering Thomas
support to deal with the on thought of
media since Harry and Megan got engaged
he continues to communicate about his
medical condition via TMZ
the source adds quote Megan has been
told by her father that he has been
unable to travel due to medical advice
from his doctors a second source tells
ET that Megan's father is a quiet humble
man and didn't anticipate being thrust
into the media spotlight just days
before his daughter's wedding I was told
by sources close to Megan last night
that she was utterly heartbroken that
she couldn't believe that this was
happening just days before her wedding
meanwhile ET has learned that Megan's
mom Maria Ragland will meet the Queen at
Windsor Castle on Friday but I think
that the Queen will be incredibly warm
and welcoming one wonders if the whole
subject of mr. Markel is going to be the
great elephant in the room but but I
know that when the Queen meets people
for the first time she really does go
out of her way to make them feel very
welcome